These are very different from traditional bidders who are utility maximizers.
They want to maximize their expected utility, which is the difference between the value and the payment.
And they don't care about the value, the ratio between value and payment.
So we understand these bidders quite well.
We have many maxims for them, like Meyerson's, VCG, hosted pricing, and others.
They are well studied.
On the other hand, for alibiders, we don't know so much.
Alibiders want to maximize their expected value, subject to the ROI constraint, which means the ratio between the expected value and the expected payment should be large enough.
We do have some maxims for them.
These maxims involve payment scalers, and sometimes we do prior-free approximations.